this time
on the incredible doctor pole highly
swede
pups in peril she just went into a grand
mal seizure
dire diagnoses it's cancelling
an all-out rescue mission that's enough
guaranteed
to ruffle some feathers this is not the
first violently we ever catch
holy cow he's a world famous vet
with thousands of patients and a team
that lives for animals
he's the incredible dr pole
doc's first client of the day it's okay
bud
also goes by doc his name is doc it's
chill out he's got to be about six or
seven and he means a lot to me
hello jim jim and julie are
bringing the [ __ ] in oh boy because
they think the horse has trouble eating
but i got a video of what it does it's
crazy
if you want to see it yeah he's chewing
his food up and he's spitting it back
out
okay so bring him out good boy
who easy easy easy easy he's so skinny
i gotta constantly be out there checking
on him to make sure
you know that he's getting something in
his stomach oh heck
he is close to 20. 20 years old
floors to 20. teeth don't lie this horse
is a lot
older this happened ah he's got a fetish
or tooth
got it good boy horses graze up to 18
hours a day it's okay oh sweetheart it's
okay
all that chewing wears at the teeth
leaving sharp edges
when the points get too long on those
teeth the horse can then
bite his own cheek or his tongue okay
head up and he thinks that there's
something in the food
so he spits the whole cut out holy cow
and when they have it bad you can see
these chewed up
cuts all over the place see that
yeah oh wow yeah but i'm gonna do try to
float them and see how many years we can
give them
horse's teeth grow their entire lives
floating helps keep things in check like
filing your nails
oh man that's bad you had to file those
points off
some of them are easy to do other ones
are not too easy to do
it sounds gnarly but after all that
chomping
this old boy's teeth are tough
hang on i gotta get a breath you gotta
catch up man yeah i don't know how
people can do this all day long
i don't know i need more muscle than i
have
you get the points off the horse
instantly feels better and eats better
the bottom sounds good hear that nice
and smooth
okay let me have a look again see that
oh my god yeah those are good
look a lot better now yeah i'm really
happy
i got a feeling it's gonna work for him
oh they were bad
but they're looking good oh i'm hoping
things go back to normal and he starts
chewing his food and swallowing it
properly instead
just spitting it back out so i can only
pray
that's all i can do from here on out
karen is new to raising sheep and has a
new lamb
that's off to a rocky start i'm worried
i don't have
any idea what to do with lambs i'm just
told that they're very fragile
and you need a lot of attention i'll
bring your lamb on back
karen's coming in with a lamb that was
born a day ago and it's weak and it's
not wanting to stand up does she move
her legs at all
no even offering to move basically a
floppy or flaccid lamb
their muscles just aren't contracting
they're not very strong they're not able
to support themselves
the lamb's weakened state could signal
many things
the first things i think about is they
didn't get colostrum or vitamin e
so that would be a reason they were a
little bit weak when they were born
does she suck a little at first she
wouldn't take much
a lack of antibodies found in the first
mother's milk
any signs that there was infection has
compromised the lamb's immune system
any baby animal i feel for i don't like
to see one hit the ground and not thrive
immediately
dr emily spots another potential cause
i'll see how nice and white that one is
looks like she had some trauma one of
the eyes has a little bit of
evidence of trauma it's got like a
pinkish hemorrhagic look to it
i'm thinking maybe the head was maybe
just a tad big for the pelvis and i had
to do some squeezing
or there was extra blood pressure built
up as the lamb was being squeezed out
and it burst the blood vessel
i'm gonna give her kind of our bag
treatment for weak
babies so what i'm gonna do for this
lamb because i had traumatic injuries
i'm gonna give it some steroids for
brain swelling it'll take some of that
down
some selenium supplementation and just
see if that helps it
come around whoa
she's not taking milk very well at least
get some sort of
uh like corn syrup in her just to give
her the energy
okay so i'll send you home with some
drugs and keep doing what you're doing
okay prognosis for this lamb is very
guarded
i'm hoping it'll pull through but i'm
not
optimistic i'm going to give it the
medicine and keep on
feeding it every couple hours yeah well
she can come on out
like every animal on my farm to be
healthy
yeah the medicine should bring down the
lamb's brain swelling
and boost her immune system it'll take
several days to see if the treatment
works
paul veterinary services this is dan
diane got a call
there was a gentleman that had a whole
bunch of birds
including two emus
and uh he died hey charles
yes so when she said do you know anybody
that wants a couple emus
charles jumped at this opportunity to
get more emus
we used to have a number of emus when i
was growing up
emus have really unique personalities
and they're really pretty they're funny
birds
they can't fly of course they can run as
fast as
anybody the ones we had before were very
friendly
we always enjoy them
[Music]
oh don't you yell at me crabby cat
this cranky cat lives up to his namesake
misty is bringing her a cat in his name
is frisky and i think he was too frisky
because he got in a fight with something
else he has a fatty inch at paw
his ears tore up and his paws all tore
up and
leaking stuff i was afraid they might
have to take it off
good morning come on he's a big guy yeah
he's not a happy camper he'll probably
growl at you oh that's okay
it's a cat oh he got bit when you see a
paw that is mangled like this
it's a bite one from another tom cat
that's bigger than what he is
he's been scheduled to get fixed but he
keeps taking off the reason is he still
is a
tomcat too and that's probably one of
the problems
oh my gosh gosh you're a tough guy
frisky is one ferocious feline i have to
give him an anesthetic
gotcha it's time to meet to change his
manners
cat fights are intense a single bite can
inflict
serious damage the teeth of these
cats are so thin and sharp
that they actually make a hole in the
skin
carry the bacterias underneath the skin
and then later on it turns to an abscess
okay i think we got all the goop out
this is uh not even an abscess it didn't
get that far
what he needs is an attitude change and
a fixer-upper frisky may be losing a
part of his manhood
but his paw will be just fine he's
keeping his foot
everything is done at the same time
castration first
and then you go to the dirty wound clean
that up
and usually in a couple of weeks
everything is healed up
and he's walking normal again when we go
home
a cat is nine lives so you know he maybe
used one of them
marilyn an emt is responding to an
emergency of her own
probie her new pup has fallen ill she's
a
six seven week old puppy that we got
yesterday
the shelter we got her from said one of
her litter mates had tested positive
for parvo they're testing the stool
right now
parvo is a viral infection they can get
it from the environment they can get it
from other dogs that are carrying it
it's
very easily transmitted it's very
contagious
they're telling me it's isolation
hospitalization
to start out with so my husband's on his
way we're gonna decide
what we're gonna do after we find out
the test
so it looks like the test is already
positive
pravo can be deadly it can be deadly
quite quickly
all right he just pulled in so yep keep
her right on this table
the thing that parvo puppies mostly die
from is the dehydration from the
diarrhea
we're already infected basically their
intestines are leaking fluids
marilyn and her husband dan also an emt
have a difficult decision she may have
to go into isolation
return their new pup to the shelter or
begin
immediate treatment it's up to you
i think so too that way of something you
guys can watch better yeah
we'll do what we can to make them better
i love her the first day we brought her
home
and we got a fight with antibiotics left
untreated
parvo has an 80 mortality rate
so the earlier you catch it the more
proactive you can be and the more likely
they are to survive
the first steps we take are to put in an
iv start rehydration
all right it's in that was the worst
part i promise
about 24 hours we'll start them on an
antibiotic
this puppy and all parvo puppies go in
isolation because it is extremely
contagious it depends on when you catch
it as to how long it'll take to recover
the next several hours will determine
how advanced the disease is
and probie's odds of surviving
[Music]
so it looks like the test is already
positive yesterday
dan and marilyn's puppy was diagnosed
with the deadly parvovirus
[Music]
the thing that parvo puppies mostly die
from is the dehydration from the
diarrhea
basically their intestines are leaking
fluids the pup was treated
and put into isolation
to prevent the virus from spreading
at the crack of dawn dr emily returns to
check on the pup's progress
probie has not been a fan of being here
since she arrived
she's torn up her cage she's turning up
her iv lines get back
oh my goodness you're gonna fall out of
your cage to me when she was tearing
stuff up it sounded like she was doing
well and she could probably go home and
finish recovering at home you're okay
you're gonna survive
there's no point in keeping her at the
hospital when she's going this crazy
hi this is dr emily at pull that calling
about probie
she is full of energy
so i think she should be able to go home
today if you just keep she'll still have
to keep an eye on her at home but
i think she'll do better at home than
here here's little probie
i was glad to see her she was a little
bit more peppy
she was moving around a lot more she
didn't look as sick as she did
y'all call me if you have any problems
okay all right thank you
both maryland and dan are emts
they'll be on 24-hour alert until the
parvo passes
and keep probie isolated so the virus
can be contained
when it comes to the spread of disease
herd and flock animals are fertile
ground for contagion
i have nine chickens at home a small
flock
a couple of them were gurgling instead
of buck bucking
i know that's a serious thing so i
thought i should come and see doc paul
as soon as possible in case it's
contagious because then we would lose
the whole flock
hello hello how are you i am fine what
you got a coughing chicken
gurgling chickens
no isofettener and i think you should be
able to handle every animal
if chickens is you know part of the sick
animals that you have to see then do it
let me see this is upper respiratory
problem with it there's actually snot
coming out of the nose just like the
people
so yes this is an upper respiratory
disease
what is this it's something that i
bought for
for respiratory problems she was using
something that she bought over the
counter
and that was not good enough this is
just an
expectorant in other words it it loosens
things up
okay expected it was basically relieving
the symptoms but not taking the cars
away
and these animals need antibiotics how
many of these chickens do you have
i have nine chickens and you have them
on what kind of bedding
straw but the last straw that was put in
there was moldy
okay get rid of it that will help a
little bit but they actually
should have antibiotic can you separate
them or not
yeah in order not to spread to the
disease to others you know separate
these two until they get better
so they do not infect all the others the
health of the flock
remains at risk until sassy and ethel
are cured
i'll advocacy one time per day
i hope that sassy and ethel will respond
to the antibiotic and that they have
better than
about a week or so
when it comes to true love there is
nothing better than a little
animal attraction she showed up to her
house one day
she was a puppy we don't know where she
came from my husband was in the garage
and we looked for her owner couldn't
find him we had her for
like two weeks and i just decided nope
we have to keep her because i'm not
sending her anywhere else
she's the best dog i couldn't ask for a
better dog
melissa and ebert have a older labrador
called kelly that has a lump on the side
and it seems like it starts to bother
her
and it was leaking fluid so we brought
her in to see him because it just looked
really bad
hiding sweet melissa says that this lump
has been
growing in size just recently what's
happening
hurt a little bit huh when i touch it on
kelly kelly whines like it's sore
see how big it is when you look at it
yeah it started to heal but then it just
kept breaking open and getting all
swollen and [ __ ] and nasty oh man that
hurts
overnight there's there's something in
there there i don't know what and then
every so often it festers up and
he says he thinks there's a foreign body
in there maybe she ran through the woods
and the stick poked in there and
who knows what but let's find out let's
take this off because this
is not just a little fatty tumor this is
probably something that
would shoot and could be removed
the lump may be cancerous
it needs to be removed and tested
it's a simple procedure to make sure
that you know everything comes out
and just suture it it's very easy and
fast to do
the hardest part of this procedure will
be waiting for the results from the
biopsy
i'll be looking at the clock all day
long until i can call and check on her
and
come and get her i don't want her to be
really sick
so i'm hoping that that's not the case
charles is prepping a roost for the
pole's newest additions
there was a gentleman down in detroit
who had a bird sanctuary
and he passed away and his children
didn't know what to do with the birds so
we're gonna take them in two of the
birds that they
have for us to rescue are emus we've had
emus before
we've always liked them the problem
before was that they
seemed to get out of the fence put them
in that deep that's all you need
perfect before the emus arrive put a
porch
in between docpole and charles need to
set up some clear boundaries
they panic easily so something can set
them off
their natural instinct is to run they'll
be a half mile away before they
they stop and this is good they're not
going through this they're not gonna
push underneath it are they
no no they're not ducks
[Music]
not one to sit on the fence doc pole
hits the road
we have all these armies clients and
they all have horses
you know they either are road horses
where they pull buggies
you know they plow with horses they
harvest with horses
and yes for them a horse is a necessity
when something goes wrong they call on
doc to make it right
how's it going i'm fine okay what what
we got
he has got something problem with the
eye
something troubling has appeared on this
guy's eye
he says he's one of our best horses yeah
i see that
that's the growth of course it's always
the best horse
it's cancer eye a debilitating condition
when you let that cancer grow it can't
see anymore it hurts
and most of the time you have to put
them down at that time
you just feel for the guy you don't want
them to lose their best horse
deep in amish country doc hopes to
prevent a horse from going blind
he says he's one of our best horses of
course it's always the best horse yeah i
see that it's cancer eye
yes if you don't do anything it can't
see anymore
it hurts and most of the time you have
to put them down at that time
so what causes that if i knew that
i'd be a millionaire because then i
could prevent it
what are the chances you can get it all
pretty good
pretty good i've done i've done many of
them actually it's not the eyeball
see right in there it's not on the
eyeball yet no
this one is still in the very beginning
it is just in the third eyelid
only and it's still at the point where
you can do it do that and save the eye
i think so you think so it's worth a try
isn't it
that's if you don't try you never win
yeah
lead rope bring them out here we'll
start knocking them down
to prevent certain blindness the
cancerous growth
must be removed from the third eyelid
most animals have three eyelets
an upper lower and one that comes from
the inside corner
going to the outside
if there's any danger like dust or
something coming
that third eyelid catches it yeah take a
look here how beautiful this is yet look
at this
see this here my dad said that this was
beautiful
in the sense that there wasn't a lot of
growth
it was pretty isolated to one specific
contact point
as doc suspected cancer hasn't spread
beyond the third eyelid
the third eyelid is the removable so
it's easy
to take the cancer off and basically
still keep the third eyelet intact
[Music]
beautiful look at this got the whole
thing
that looks better now yep that's what i
wanted man
okay perfect
the way i cut this out because you're so
early
it probably dies of old age before it
bothers her again
that's the way it sounds to me this
gentleman called fatty early
it came out so clean i wish everybody
would call in time like that
[Music]
thanks to some quick action okay thank
you
this horse should have a long productive
life the prognosis for this horse is
very good
we have a puppy coming in she was here
earlier for parvo treatment and she was
getting better but now this morning they
called and said it
sounds like she's either choking or
having a seizure she flopped right over
and just went into a grand mal seizure
weird there's a couple of things that
could cause seizure
water it looks weak it could be just
dehydration and the
electrolytes being off balance
could be an infection that's reached the
brain
there's a bunch of different things that
could be going on i think she can see
testing probie's sensory and motor
skills she's avoiding things
will indicate if she suffered any
permanent brain damage
she's just acting really weak
okay my goodness i will pick you up
neurologically probie checks out just
fine
well i would say keep an eye on her okay
now we don't want to start them on
anti-seizure medication unless
they're confirmed right i didn't put
probi on seizure medication because i
don't believe that probie has epilepsy i
think she has seizures relating to her
disease process
at least the diarrhea stopped and she
hasn't thrown up since
thursday night probing not vomiting and
not having diarrhea are definitely good
science she's at least retaining her
hydration levels at this point
we just kind of have to get her feeling
better and eating again keeping probie
well hydrated
and medicated should help prevent
further disease-related seizures
okay well let's see how she does
hopefully she does not have any more
problems
yes yes both of probie's owners are
emts so she'll be in good hands
throughout the recovery process
carbo can last normally around five to
ten days
uh it depends on when you catch it as to
how long it'll take to recover
[Music]
yesterday callie had a potentially
cancerous growth removed from her side
a tissue sample was sent out to be
tested to determine if it was cancer
i don't want her to be really sick so
i'm hoping that that's not the case
the moment of truth has arrived dr paul
told me that there was nothing in there
that looked bad
everything looked good and he was able
to get everything out of there
cali is no longer in pain
and there is no sign of cancer
dogs are actually part of the family so
when their
owners then come back they usually are
very exuberant
and in a case like this it definitely
shows you know labs are lovable animals
by mid-morning the poles are ready to
motor to detroit
and begin their mission of mercy yeah
and charles and i are going to go down
to the city and we're going to pick up
some birds
as a rescue are you driving i guess
beautiful it's gonna be at least a two
and a half to three hour trip to go down
one way
we will have to load the birds up and
then bring them back
should be quite interesting getting them
home there was definitely not the best
day to go get the birds
it was a torrential downpour it turns
out to be
a rainy day like we've had so many this
spring
undaunted by the downpour the poles
head south for the day while docks away
there's no time for the vets to play
i had a u-lamb yesterday
i found her today in the uterus prolapse
this is the first time she slammed i
hope to use her again for five or six
years
this sheep has been through a lot she
pro-ups her uterus it's been out for a
while
she's been down came down here and found
her
she's just a wreck if she lives i'm
gonna be ecstatic
i'm not sure i would think we can get
that far
dr brenda is on an emergency call to
help you in trouble
they have got a sheep that's prolapsed
came down here and found her
she's just a wreck you know this is a
traumatic event for her
and a lot of times they just give up
this is the first time she slammed
i hope to use her again for five or six
years
a country vet needs to make do with
what's on hand
what we're going to try to do is put our
back end up in the air to help give us
some leverage
so i'm using a couple square bales of
straw just to lift her hind end up
this tilts the pelvis so that i can work
on it easier
hold still sheep plus it just makes it a
more comfortable height for me to work
at because now i'm working at my waist
instead of having to lay on the floor
behind her and do something
all right now i'll take your warm water
she's got some discoloration to this
uterus when you look at it part of it's
still got decent color on it part of it
does not so
the uterus has got a real dark spot on
it i'm very concerned about the
quality of the uterus these are all kind
of a crap shoot anyway
right i'm just hoping she gets the
uterus back in and you'll be usable i've
got it all
inside the vagina but it's not straight
yet so i got to work a little bit
thank yet so it's gone part way i'm
gonna let it sit for a minute just
hopefully some gravity and letting her
move it around a little bit we'll get it
back to where we want it to be
all i'm doing is just giving the uterus
time to shrink down a little bit trying
to get it back so it's
straightened out right side out inside
the u
okay all right we got everything
straightened out
um what are you going to do with her
we're going to keep her and breed her
again she's
she's just first time lamer okay warren
would really love her to breed back
again get pregnant again have more
babies
i'm not sure i would think we can get
that far
a few stitches will keep everything
secure during the healing process
now more in this stitch should stay in
about three or four days and then you
can take it out
all right everything is in its proper
place but there is still cause for
concern
most sheep when they lay down like this
they never get up they're good until
they're not good and when they're not
good they're bad
yeah the adage for sheep are a six sheep
is a dead sheep
i think they just get sick and their
brain function says
die not even try to get better just i'm
sick i must die
surprisingly she makes an immediate
u-turn
your mom do you want some of this she
drinks some water and i thought
wow look what happened she don't think
she's been up to have water since
yesterday when she landed
oh that's awesome it is she did actually
get herself up she's
standing up i think that's a good sign
acted like she wanted to live
i'm quite excited about that but she's
got a long ways to go before she's back
to healthy
there's not much more i can do with her
right now it's all
sort of out of our hands other than
warren providing some food and some tlc
for her
she's gonna live or die based on what
she feels like
hope the rest of your landing goes
uneventfully and twins and
everything's good from there i'm not
saying she's out of the woods yet
i'm saying we have a glimmer of hope but
it's a sheep
earlier this week this is upper
respiratory problem with this what is
this
doctor treated two chickens for an upper
respiratory infection
i did what doc paul suggested and in a
matter of about four days
they were fine and back to their old
socks and no longer in danger of
contaminating the rest of the flock
come on sweetie they're healthy as can
be
and no problems
she's beautiful isn't she happy chickens
are so much fun
nice eggs you get nice eggs out of them
and they sing for you
i'm feeling great i'm happy i have happy
chickens
back up child back up the car
after a two and a half hour road trip
get the trailer
lined up first cause we're not gonna
want those emus forever
the poles are ready to launch their
avian rescue mission
okay hi dr pope hi dr
paul i'm randy wendy yeah and i'm anne
marie rogers we spoke on the phone
after randy's father roger passed she
and ann
were left with a flock of birds and no
way to take care of them
i was at a loss as to who would take on
all these birds
last resort would have been to take them
to a shelter and have them euthanized
which i never wanted
to do roger's favorite feathered friends
were a pair of emus named george and
gracie
these birds were roger's passion
and they're about 20 to
23 years old oh yeah emus can
easily get up to 35 years of age
biggest problem is like had happened
here that these birds
outlive the owner let me go in first i
don't know how
tame they are but normally i can do
something with them
we were surprised to see that the emus
were in quite a large pen
let me see what they can do and how tame
they are and they had not been handled
the way ours had been handled
hi girls i don't know it's gonna be sort
of a roundup
come on i think that's gonna be the
toughest part of our day here
holy cow you guys stay out emus
can kick as hard as a horse almost
that's enough they have a very strong
breast bone that's what they fight with
they do actually a chest bump
doc's rescue mission turns into a
featherweight bout
holy moses
randy randy and i'm anne-marie the poles
are on a mission
to rescue two emus let me go in first
we were surprised to see that the emus
were in quite a large pen
let me see what they can do and how tame
they are
emus are definitely not weak you guys
stay out
they have some muscle to them for sure
emus
may be flightless but they're far from
defenseless
emus can kick as hard as a horse almost
with super sharp claws that can inflict
serious damage
okay charles bring the tarp catch him in
there
for the safety of both friend and foul
doc
decides to use a tarp the tarp is just
to be have it in between people so that
they cannot just run by you
they're gonna see that as a wall that
they can't get through
we gotta go this way they're getting
scared slow down
emus have body language
the male is really scared when you stand
up straight
that means they're looking up because
there's danger
when you bend over okay walk up a little
more people now they catch that body
language and this oh
everything is all right and they quit
runner okay woke up
this way i think it's quite impressive
to see the way
careful ian can look at the animal and
kind of
gauge what the animal is gonna do it's
okay now
it's okay if you watch animals you can
know how to catch them the easiest
come on okay move in move right hey
bring her back they won't hurt you at
upwards of 90 pounds
hang on these aussie natives shouldn't
be taken lightly
watch it watch it they can get
very wild hey cooling they are very
strong and they can hurt
and it was kind of risky and scary
i got a socket air good job when you put
a sock over their hat and they can't see
they will not run as fast or try to get
away from you
wow his high kicker they can still kick
holy cow and that's not all
they have a very strong breast bone
that's what they fight with when they
fight with each other they jump up they
do
actually a chest bump and the whole
secret is
you hold on to that big bone in their
chest
and yes that's enough they'll jump up
and down they kick
but you got them oh yeah
this was the hard part charles yeah i
think the other birds will be easier
yeah with the two big birds in hand
hi guys time to scoop the rest of the
flock
but these birds are two game for the
hook yeah this hook is too big for them
they will have to be rescued by hand
it's hard to catch birds you got to have
quick reactions
i got two already oh you're good and you
know my dad knows how to handle him
i got a big one so i mean he caught the
majority of them i don't think i could
have done
it like he did let's keep going not in
the time he did
i got you i got you he's been working
with animals for like 50 years
that's how he's got so good more cases
and more birds
in under two hours doc and the team
rescue almost
40 birds we've always had a bunch of
birds
so now we're gonna have these peacocks
and turkeys
at our house too
that's the last one that's the last one
wow
awesome i'd like to think that where my
dad is
he's beaming down light because he must
be really happy
that his beloved birds are going to dr
paul
mom he wrangled george all by himself
the emu yeah yeah this is not the first
violet we ever catch
she wanted them to go to a place that
she knew they would be
loved and well taken care of then
they'll give it a hug
thank you you're very we'll take care of
them
and so it was kind of like passing on
the legacy from her father to someone
else that really cared about him yeah
no those years will have a good home
honestly
i don't think there's no other place
better for the birds than dr paul
it's wheels up doc hits the road
earlier dr emily treated a newborn
that's not good
too weak to even stand basically a
floppy or flaccid lamb
and their muscles just aren't
contracting they're not very strong
looks like she had some trauma i'm
thinking maybe the head was maybe just a
tad big for the pelvis and i had to do
some squeezing
i'm gonna give her kind of our bag
treatment for a week
babies any baby animal i feel for i
don't like to see one hit the ground and
not thrive immediately
the lamb had a precarious start there
you go kid
thanks to dr emily he sprung back into
health
within a few days it was trying to stand
up
walk and get around so that was a really
nice thing
you getting tired i'm very happy that
it's
running around being happy huh
you're a mess i'm already attached to
that little lamb
i'm really excited that this lamb is
coming back and it's doing better i
think has a much better prognosis
by early evening the poles make it home
with their new
feathered friends it's been a long day
it's been wet
tiring and kind of scary at times hi
guys
welcome to you know home you little
terps the barn will be a temporary roost
for the birds
until they relocate to the pole's lake
house
you know i'm in there every day charles
is in there every day
and it makes it a lot nicer for them so
that they see more people
walking around and that way they get a
lot tamer that's all of them right
yep okay so the emu's can come out it
was a little bit of
uh a little bit of an adventure to
capture those birds
you can walk with me and talk with me no
that's far enough
you're going this way no you don't have
to jump
it just gives you a kind of a warm
feeling inside that you know that you're
doing something good to help the animals
and it's rewarding okay
come on buddy okay that's good
we got them in the pan the sun is
setting
i think they're going to be happy here
after a couple weeks yeah
they're a little bit skeptical but i'm
hoping over time they
they begin to realize who i am and come
around and
we become friends let's go let them
be in peace for tonight
it's late afternoon but dr brenda is
still kicking up some dust
at myrons a first-time mom is in the
battle of her life
this cabin for myron is an emergency
problem this heifer has got a cap in it
his feet and nose are all here together
um the calf is coming sort of all at one
time a fatal abnormality
that can kill both mom and calf we'd
like to save them both but
possibilities we won't at least we can
save the call maybe
[Music]
dr brenda is on a life and death
emergency call
this heifer has got a cap in it feet and
nose are all here together
the legs are bent so the heifer can't
push the calf out the calf has been
trapped for hours
in order to get the baby out she's gonna
have to lay over often with these
heifers when they've had a calving
that's
lasted a long time they're not making
any progress with it a lot of times
these calves are dead
okay let's let her stay free here we'll
see what we can do with her
a dead calf becomes toxic threatening
the life of the mother the sooner it's
out
the more likely the cow will survive
what i find is there is a huge calf
coming out of a small heifer
there's not enough room hardly to even
try to get the chain passed up onto the
other foot
i'm literally pushing the chain on this
calf with one finger because that's all
i can get in between
everything that's here there's only room
for one chain
on one hoof so i'm gonna hope by
pulling on the leg we have that that
will help bring the other foot out
enough we get a chain on that one and
help us
once we get the chain placed we can get
the feet pulled out a little bit
replace our chains into a better pulling
configuration and then get the jack
attached to that and work the cap out
with the extra leverage
hold still cow and a ton of elbow grease
push the hips out and you'll be done the
calf
is pulled free all right i always hope
that they're going to be live man this
baby's dead
yeah i think so no heartbeat it does not
surprise me that this one was dead
i'm pretty sure myron wasn't surprised
because of the fact that i've been
partially delivered for
several hours let's see if there's
anybody else in there i hope not but
we'll see
his concern is can we get the heifer up
there is no other calf in here
good okay then we're gonna hope she gets
up
whether that happens today like right
this minute or not i'm not sure
i think if i was a betting person i'd
say she can't get up um i'm gonna give
her some meds to help with the swelling
and the pressure since she's had the
baby the
calf is large and having it in the
pelvis for a long time presses on the
obturator nerves
that run the back legs of the cow all
right let's let her sit here for a few
minutes and
just recuperate from all her trauma
we're really concerned about
does she have feeling and can she use
her back end there's not much more than
time and tlc for her at this point
there you go there you go oh careful
careful i'm actually quite surprised
that she got herself
up just take a minute she walks
oddly which i'm not surprised about i'm
just really happy that she's on her feet
come on there babes byron and i decided
to put her back
out in the field get out there just be
careful on the mud
so she would have better footing than
being on the slippery cement
byron i'm gonna go all right i thank you
very much yep
the bad news is we had a dead calf the
good news is the heifer got up which
was questionable when we got done with
the calving
knfc 707 level three to base okay
so we can move forward from here
after a few touch and go weeks probie
has won her battle against the deadly
parvo virus
ruby's doing wonderful we were so happy
that she finally made that corner and
she's
doing great now where'd it go
probie means probationary firefighter my
husband is captain on the fire
department and she's the unofficial
mascot the guys love her
occasionally she goes on a run she's
playful
she's just like a little puppy that's
never been sick
hey guys uh dad can you come out and uh
look at my emos for me yeah let's do
that
i want to come too as long as you don't
scare them
i don't scare anybody
charles wants us to take a look at his
emails that's not his emus they're our
emus
fema's been here for about a month and i
think that they've settled in incredibly
well
hey hi buddy they're fantastic they're
funny birds they're like little
velociraptors in there
they just walk the perimeter checking
the fence the integrity
just checking for weaknesses pretty
dinosaurific to me
i think they gain weight you know that
they have games oh yeah
yeah they are much more friendly than
when we first got them
too i'm happy that we could give these
emails a home
i think they like it here
a few months back dr brenda treated a u
with a prolapsed uterus
she's now sheared and in shape she never
moved
at all for a day or so but then she got
up and she's just been going meeting and
she's a handful we're gonna still go
ahead and breed her this fall
it's a blessing to have her alive today
[Music]
[Music]
you